- Right now, I'm standing
in a particularly
depressing part of Van Nuys, California
that was never repaired after the war.
This is the legendary Ironhead Studio.
That's right, Ironhead Studio
where they make many of the costumes
for giant franchise superhero films.
Films that make billions and
billions of dollars in profit.
We're gonna go inside and meet the
geniuses that make these costumes.
We're gonna find out how they do it,
why they do it, who does
it, when they do it.
Eliminate those last two.
(loud air pressure)
The building just farted.
(laughter)
That's how shitty it is here.
But, there are geniuses inside.
Let's go check it out.
(exciting music)
This is Jose Fernandez, Jose,
really cool to meet you.
- Same, same.
- You did the most recent
Ben Affleck Batman?
You probably measured
every inch of his body.
- Yes.
(laughter)
(cheering crowd)
It's amazing, the minute you put this on,
your whole attitude changes.
(laughter)
I would demand to be seated
first in a restaurant.
(laughter)
Gal Gadot, let's talk
about her for a second.
She was on my show and
stunning, such a stunning,
very nice, but my God
is Gal Gadot beautiful.
- Yeah.
- Good God.
Just gonna think about
her for a little bit.
(laughter)
They can pull this out in editing,
I just wanna think about Gal Gadot.
(sexy music)
What are you thinking about?
- [Voiceover] Perv.
(laughter)
- Of course that's the
iconic Batman helmet.
You did sort of wonder when I was watching
the movie, why doesn't Superman just
use his heat vision to burn his mouth?
- Well, here I am.
(loud screaming)
(laughter)
- Yeah, you got a point.
- This is I think Sumner Redstone.
(laughter)
I love this right here.
I call this me before coffee and
then that's me after coffee.
(laughter)
Immediate transformation.
And, of course, I'm
recognizing Matt Damon.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
There's Ben Affleck right there.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, yeah.
- Ian McKellen!
- Hugh Jackman behind you.
- Oh, is this Hugh Jackman?
- Yeah.
- If Hugh Jackman walked in and
he say that those other actors were
placed up there and he was shoved
on top of the old stereo receiver,
he'd be mad.
You mind if I?
- No.
(laughter)
- Oh, look at that.
Okay.
We know he's not Jewish.
Look, he's just pretending
that this isn't happening.
(laughter)
Check this out.
I'd rather not.
(laughter)
- This is the Wonder Woman.
- This is actually her body.
- Yeah.
- An exact replication Gal Gadot's body.
- Yeah, this is her body then we
repositioned it for promotions.
- Has anyone here ever put the Matt Damon
head in the other room onto this?
- No.
- Just to perv out?
Oh my God, this is fantastic.
(cheering crowd)
What do you mean it's wrong?
In a world where gender I think is
becoming more fluid, this
is an amazing statement.
Uh?
Oh, yes.
Dear boy, what have you
done to me, dear boy?
You shall not pass!
(laughter)
I've come to Jose because I want
to have a super hero costume made for me.
I would like it to be sexy
and appealing to women.
Feel free to get in there and examine.
What do you think?
- You definitely have small calves.
- What, small calves?
- Calves, yep.
- I think mine are bigger than yours.
(laughter)
- Okay, well, yes.
I'm imagining that with some actors
you enhance a certain region down south.
- Some you enhance, some you minimize.
- I would like that to be.
- Enhanced?
- Enhanced almost to the point
of the movie couldn't be released.
(laughter)
Maybe this isn't important because
I've always heard women do not care
at all about the size of that area.
It's completely irrelevant to
their attraction to the man
and that's just a man's fixation but
women actually prefer a much smaller penis
is what I've often been told.
(laughter)
So, one area we haven't brought
up is that I have no ass.
What I'm saying is that
there's just nothing.
What are you doing, you
think this is helping me?
Why does it always have to
be ha ha, look at the freak?
(laughter)
What do we do to begin?
- Start with body scan and measurements.
(exciting music)
- And, this is for when I'm
inevitably scared and defeated.
(exciting music)
(laughter)
(cheering crowd)
(exciting music)
We have a great show tonight!
From the new movie Sausage
Party, Nick Kroll is here!
The Green Arrow, The Flash and Supergirl!
Stephen Amell, Grant Gustin
and Melissa Benoist are here.
Musical guest Weird Al Yankovich.
We'll be right back, Jimmy take it away.
(cheering crowd)
(exciting music)